So now I would like to wrap up this lesson
by going back to our discussion of rational unified process
phases and iterations. So to do that I'm going to bring
back the presentation that I used before, the summary representation
about phases and traditional software engineering activities. And I want to
use this representation to stress and discuss a couple of
things. Mainly I want to recap it because I think
it is very important. What is the relation between the rational
unified process, and the traditional software engineering phases, and software
engineering activities? And I like to do it now that
we have discussed the phases in a little more detail.
So I want to make sure that it is clear by now
how and when the traditional software engineering activities, the ones
listed here, take place in the context of the RUP
phases, the four listed up here. For instance, it should
be clear why implementation takes place mainly in the construction phase.
Why requirements engineering is prominent in the elaboration phase
and why deployment activities occur mostly in the transition phase,
and so on. So it should be clear now
why the activities are so distributed in the four phases.
It should also be clear that although there is
normally one main phase for each activity, the activities really
span multiple phases. Which is actually one of the interesting
aspect of RUP. So the fact that you're not really
done with an activity even in later phases. Why? Well, because that allows
you, in subsequent iterations, to address
problems that came up in previous iterations.